[Music]
welcome everyone thank you so much for
being here today especially thank you
because this is kind of the last session
of the last day it's a three days
conference with pretty long a lot of
work and we're very excited to see you
still stay here today and that's the
right choice because actually when we
first got the schedule they say we're
you know the very last one we're
actually asked can we you know move it
to the day before etc so more people may
attend but they say no you can't we
can't because you're talking to
important and you know the order of the
talks ordered by the increasing of the
importance so we're the last one but
it'll be happy to find out that's the
important that you made it right we'll
make sure you learn all the important
things you might find very helpful so
that you can end your conference on the
strongest note my name is Sophia yang
product manager from the compute engine
team join me today are three gentlemen
here we have a cache our developer from
the cloud security team and we have
cereal so product manager from compute
engine team and we'll have Niek from two
sigma a customer joining us to tell us
the story about how 2 Sigma is utilizing
our tools to build their most security
environment
so privacy and security has always been
the top party at Google when a milk
builded help you build at the most a
security environment and that's why
every year we continuously invest and
the beauty new features new tools to
help you achieve that goal and the words
mentioning not only we're building this
environment for you guys
we're also using this ourselves many
products applications from Google also
running on Google cloud and today we're
making our secret sauce our best
practice our perspectives into six
simple steps who walk you through step
by step how to build the most a security
environment and when talking about
getting started before I share any best
practice yet let's just first look at
how people mostly get started with cloud
we find out no matter you're one of the
fortune 500 company with thousands
employees or you're just individual
developer often when you get started
with Google cloud you're on a first
start by trying all the new cool
features testing out the performance and
at that face performance access
management is kind of the last thing I
want to worry about and we understand
that that is why we make the getting
started state is super simple and easy
for you you come to cool cloud you
create a project you automatically it's
the owner of the project you have full
access within the project don't have to
worry too much about who can access a
resource because your project is created
as an isolating environment so no one
else can access your unit your resources
within a project all this is trying to
minimize your time to finish your
proof-of-concept to finish your
prototype so make sure you can totally
fall in love it's a Google cloud and
then when you're done with your
prototype what do you do next
you're ready to move your production
workload or your dev and test
environment unto us and that is when we
should start talking about how to build
the most secure environment and that
takes us to step 1 create an
organization so we're creating
organization is so important because
after afterwards it's much easier to
apply organizational why the policy if
you have organization and the talking
about building organization the first
assuming you do is to set how the
organization is it
and so let's see my cache here to tell
more about how to do that
thank Sofia the first things that you
need to do to get any kind of security
for your cloud is to is to essentially
root your trust in the identities in in
your in your system without securing
your identities and the identities that
can access your resources there really
is no help in securing the rest of your
cloud and that means that you need an ID
any story you need either in provider
and you need policies that you can apply
to those identities and the here at
Google we have two we have we have
solutions to get you started here for no
matter what kind of company you are if
you're in the first way that you and in
two ways to general paths in which you
can establish your identity store at
Google the first is to use Google as
your as your identity provider itself
and I'm sure that many of you do this
already Google does this internally we
use our products internally all the time
the basic there's a fully fledged
identity system with groups and users
and API is to manage them security
controls and so forth and so on and it's
also conveniently very easy to set up
for a small provider small customers of
Google Cloud if you're an established
shop and you have an existing identity
system such as Active Directory or an
LDAP system you can use Google cloud act
or Google cloud directory sync to
synchronize those identities and groups
to Google and use them and apply them in
policies in the Google cloud product the
next thing after establishing your
identity story Google Cloud you need to
secure your secure them somehow and
fortunately at Google we've basically
been working on securing clouds for many
many years now first with our internal
cloud product but also for now with our
external cloud products we've been
dealing with attacks on our internal
resources in X and and our customers
resources from state actors non-state
actors you name it we probably seen it
and we have a lot of researchers and and
security engineers just
tracking all of the incidents that we
can find things maybe the rest of the
world hasn't even discovered yet and we
then also work on trying to mitigate
those those those attacks with new
tooling and features that that sometimes
we apply internally but then sometimes
we should we give to you to apply to
your own resources and I'm going to give
you a list of basically a few of the
things that I think that you should be
turning on basically out-of-the-box for
ensuring that your your cloud is secure
the first thing I want to talk about is
- two-factor authentication and security
keys we've been using these internally
for a couple years now and they have
been super effective at eliminating all
sorts of account attacks and phishing
attacks the basic idea is that your
users get a your developers get a
security key and this is a hard to fish
a security device that has to be present
every time that your users log in your
developers login and so what that means
is that if someone can steal my password
or trick me into answering questions
an attacker can't actually login unless
they're in possession of the of the
secure device as well to configure your
systems use this you can go to the
Google cloud min console and you can go
to the security settings and turn on the
security keys this is so important we've
actually just announced our own security
key products which should be coming to
market at some point in the future the
second thing after you've secured your
accounts themselves is to secure your
connected applications to your to your
identities the I'm sure all of you have
seen in the news with various incidents
the basically if a third-party
application can connect to your users
and get their data from the cloud and
from a cloud provider the it's unclear
what that third-party provider might do
with the data
and this means that this is like one
situation when you have your your social
media data being collected by a by an
attacker by a third party company it's
another thing entirely when it's your
corporate resources that are being and
being stolen
so the
and basically in these situations your
developers you just need to trick one
and developer in your company to install
an application or on their phone or on
their on their browser and all of a
sudden access to your your corporate
resources could be granted so we highly
recommend that you go to the Google
admin console and turn off all connected
applications for all scopes on all ap
eyes that are important to you in
particular for the Google cloud platform
maybe others and then at some point if
you need to actually have developers use
delegate access to applications either
first party applications or applications
from vendors you trust you can vet those
applications and you can use the trusted
app app configuration tools to whitelist
individual apps to have access to
individual services now I here I think I
know what most of you people are now
thinking you're probably thinking this
is great cash but the thing that really
keeps me awake at night are the
attackers working from their undersea
lairs trying to get access to my cloud I
want to tell you that I to worry about
these kinds of situations and we
basically we just announced the other
day our new set of security features
around protecting access to your cloud
resources to what we call secure
contacts or access contexts and the
basic idea is that I can configure in my
in my cloud console the set of Networks
or VPNs that should have access to my
cloud resources and essentially mitigate
and prevent accesses to my resources
from outside of those those networks and
the good thing about this is not only
does it help mitigate against attacks
from deep sea undersea layers it also
helps protect from attackers in in
volcano fortresses or even moon bases
and the final thing I want to tell you
about organizations at Google is in
Google cloud is that they give you an
incredibly powerful tool to organize and
manage your resources in a way that
makes sense to your business in
particular we find that organizations
are often broken up into individual
product areas and so
times with different types of
deployments like for instance internally
at Google we often speak about developer
like dev level environments staging
level environments and production level
environments and you can actually model
these things in folders and and
different projects and apply policies
that apply it down here are quickly
through the policy hierarchy essentially
so that you can apply a policy hi and in
the policy treant to apply to all
resource on our resources underneath or
for instance if something makes sense
only for us a specific product area you
can apply a policy to only the resources
within that in that product area and
with that I'd like to turn over to
Sophia to teach us about step two all
right thank you so much cash so now
great you have set up your organization
you have sync the order said about your
organization identity so sinker identity
from on prime so now I realize you have
thousands employees on cloud so how can
you manage the access of them how can
you make sure the great person can
perform their job like your developers
can go ahead deploy code in our code
base also you don't give everyone a
superpower array and that is when you
need to set up your Identity and Access
Management or most people called I am so
I am in a nutshell is really about
giving you the control to set who can
perform which actions on what resources
so in an actual example for example I
can say I want a grand cash the instance
admin role to my test project that's
gonna allow cash to manipulated my
instances in the test project I created
the etc I can also grant say sorry the
storage admin role in my project the
same project and Siri can then access my
data that is thrown in a GCS bucket yet
sir II wouldn't be able to manipulate my
VM instance because he's not instance
admin the same thing cash wouldn't be
access it GCS back unless they kind of
coordinate right but they could think
that's what I am can now you a fine
granular control of who can do what so
then now you probably can realize wow I
have so thousands employees the policy
sounds like will look very complicated
don't be panic no matter how and the
result might look complicated the steps
you are taking out to the set of the IMS
are always the same the policy language
is always the same which the steps will
follow is first create our IM policy and
then set the policy on a target resource
so let's first look at what is Pam
policy looks like here is here is a JSON
example as you can tell policy contains
a list of bindings and so within each
binding you define members and roles and
in this example all these members
assigned with the same image user role
so let's take a deeper look at members
which is the circular part we allow
three types of identities at Google
Cloud one is the users which the human
users to service accounts who are the
identities of VMs services so they're
the representation for robots pretty
much in the groups obviously the group
of multiple things and that they you can
put both human users and the service
accounts into one group and next let's
look at the rows the rows are I am rows
which is really a collection of
permissions so now let's take a deeper
look at a water rows can be at Google
with support three times I am rows the
first two types are primitive rows and
the predefined rules there are three
types within the primitive rows only
three owner editor and viewers the each
have a wire Y very wide access and very
wide set of permissions there are many
to remember we said again start a state
where are meant to get you started
quickly but yes they are really not
meant for production for exactly the
same reason there are two cores there
have to each have two wide access of the
permissions so what should you use in
production system predefined rows or
sometimes called curators what are they
they are just really fine-grained rows
that Google defined for you that's
specifically targeting a specific use
case for example instance Admirals are
most likely mapped to your developer
functionalities and thus to network
admin
probably you'll give it to your network
admins as the name sounds that can help
you set up the network's firewalls VPNs
before a developer comes to deploy code
and our backs practice there is always
used at least privilege role so do not
grant any additional permissions and as
needed
that's for your security purpose and the
other the better implement is least a
privilege principle we also have a third
type of I am rose which is custom emeral
women is offering publicly available
earlier this year as the name suggests
is allowing you to customize your
permissions you wanna precisely put into
your role so there are two typical use
cases that you need to use custom I am
ro1s D you may realize our predefined
roles are still too limited like some
customers saying I have to sometimes
assign two or three predefined roles to
each identity to do their job and if you
know I scale is a little harder to
manage like many people I start used to
have both log of euros and the monitor
of euros in this example so then you can
create your own custom role to combine
these two roles together and going
forward you can just assign this
particular custom role another use case
this is the opposite some customers find
out our predefined roles are still too
wide or doesn't necessarily mean exactly
their business needs a popular example
will be instance admin role they want to
get to that developer they want
everything about it except that its own
IP usage for you know extra filtration
infiltration so they don't want a
developer to be able to create VMs with
exon ID so they will just easily remove
that particular permission from the
existing role and accredit your own
developer admin role and next let's
since we learn about I am policies you
know roles and identities let's talk
about a few best practices how to
implement those in the most a security
way the first recommendation we give to
you is always assign permissions and
access to groups now to individual users
so why is that I know it's very natural
to think about oh I have rows we should
assign to those users directly but think
about your employees could move around
within a company
if you directly giving them rose
permissions on themselves after a while
you might realize as harder to track and
not to understand what this permissions
this employee current list you need
maybe he was in a different group and I
needed some something else but now he
doesn't but after a while it's very hard
to analyze analyze and there's so that
you couldn't achieve the least
privileged principle right but I'm
different if you can assign permissions
to account a group and then add or
remove users from groups say so when one
employee leaves a certain group they get
removed from the group they
automatically lose all those permissions
they had before it's much easier and a
cleaner to manage the access for
employees and at the same time service
accounts do not change roles and move
around as humans so we recommend you
directly set policies on service
accounts so that's the first principle
and also best practice grant access to
groups here's another one that we have
seen a lot of success from our customers
which is brick glass tile one of the
approach is if your by the way if you're
not familiar this term think about fire
distinguisher on the wall right they're
protected by the glass so that if there
is a fire you can access it by breaking
a glass but that's very invasive action
takes a lot of additional caution to do
it and by doing so you kind of prevented
a lot of accidental external errors so
one of the style to implement this brick
style brick glass is to assign human
users nothing but the project admin I am
Admiral what is particular you're only
allowed is set permissions set policies
that's it so if you give your uncle this
particular role they wouldn't be able to
just go ahead to stop your VM in
production system because they can't
they don't have the permission but yet
as we said it's called a pre class so if
emergency arises if there's an urgent
situation they do have to go ahead and
manipulate your VM instance they can use
that they're poor jack I am admin role
to grant themselves this is the instance
admin role and from there they can go
ahead and manipulate VM instance but
then this actually of caution actual
requirements can help you prevent a lot
of accidental actions and by the
way all these change of policy setting
policies are in audit log so you can go
back to trace that and with that I'm
sure many of you already have questions
just wanna know more about service
accounts so let's see my cashback to
tell more about the service accounts
thanks as most of you guys know service
accounts are quite fun toys to play with
they tireless you execute all of our
actions for us when we're not there at
the keyboard they they run our jobs they
run our services they they never get
paid and yet they're always there for us
but sometimes they're hard to understand
and so I'd like to first help you get to
know what the service accounts that we
offer look like and feel like and how to
differentiate them and make sense of
them as you and as you encounter them
this is a common cause of confusion and
errors that we see when we talk to our
external customers this is an IM policy
page that you see in the google cloud
developer console and this is the
landing page when you get to I am as you
can see this I am indicates this is an
ion policy this is the policy that
grants access to this project and all
the resources contained within as Sofia
was indicating earlier policy is
essentially just a mapping of the sets
of permissions to assets of identity so
for instance this grant grants me owner
on this project this is a service
account you can tend to identify them by
the fact that they end in G service
account com email addresses the name
here indicates what it is it's a service
gap that was created by default by the
system to get me started using the cloud
it has editor access which is fairly
powerful and clearly this is not a
production project right everything that
we told you before about securing your
projects was not done here and so you
could imagine what that might look like
here you've taken cash at Google calm
you've granted him project I am in
you've taken well I you actually granted
him project I am admin through his his
presence on a team called team David
the service account at the top has been
granted cloud data store user because of
all it is doing is accessing data store
for instance and so this makes sure that
if the jobs compromised the impact and
blast radius is limited to two data
store and not for instance my VMs or
other things these other service
accounts here in the middle are a common
cause of confusion for our customers and
they represent the the identities of
services activated and essentially
purchased from Google the I didn't
create them I don't own them and I don't
manage them they're owned and managed by
Google and protected for you they're
secure kept securely under lock and key
for only our production services to
access they've been granted cert
particular API access to your resources
in this project and they specifically
grant access to only the types of data
that and and and operations that are in
line with the business requirements of
those of those services and we basically
review every one of those security grant
every one of those grants before we
allow them to be granted to your
projects to make sure that they actually
make logical sense and meet your
expectations if I want to look at the
service accounts that I own and I manage
you can flip to the service account tab
and here you can see that I have two
service accounts one the default one
that we told you was created earlier by
by the system for me to get me started
but I also created another one called
web my web Fe which I'm using to run my
my web front-end the the there are two
ways that you can use these service
accounts the first way is to use what we
call Google manage credentials which
essentially means that you don't have to
worry about any of the key management or
the rotation story we keep the service
accounts secure for you we it's a
tireless task but somebody's got to do
it you don't pay me enough to do that
but we make sure that they always get
rotated for you and they're kept secure
the basic idea here is that I can ask a
service like Google compute or Google
App Engine or Google cloud functions
to use a service account here I'm asking
for instance compute service to to
create an instance bound to my front-end
service account and what happens is an
act as check of permission code actives
will be checked to make sure that I have
permission to use the service account
and bind it to a job and then once I'm
I've been granted access that job will
run continuously without me being there
as that service account and that service
and that in the end the code inside the
VM can go and access data commiserate
with the permissions that have been
granted to the service again the other
way of using service accounts is to
download a service account key and this
is less secure we think way of managing
your service accounts and using your
service accounts because you have to
take responsibility for making sure that
key doesn't leak and you have to take
responsibility for rotating that key to
keep it secure it's predominantly there
for you to use when connecting all your
on-premise systems to Google cloud
platform for instance if you needed to
do database backup or or computer backup
or something like this to compute a
cloud storage you could use a service
account key to do that many of you are
acute customers I'm sure and you've seen
in the user interfaces and the api's and
the command lines that when you create
VMs we often ask you for a set of access
control scopes or just scopes when
you're creating a VM we call these VM
lock scopes essentially they're a legacy
feature of compute from the days before
Google I am came on the scene they
caused some confusion to our customers
and so I'd like to clarify some of the
usage here they used to be used for some
coarse grained access control but
they're not really good for that these
days so we highly recommend that in
general when you see these things you
close your eyes and don't use them for
access control we rely on I am for
access control and instead give the give
the VM fairly high level scope such as
Google cloud platform or full access it
depending on the user interface you're
using and if you need to call other
api's like calendar or maps or or
something you can grant those scopes as
well and I think Sofia has something
more to tell you about managing your
resources yep
all right thank you cash yep so now we
have got our employee imported here in
the Google cloud and a set of IM
policies onto them
also set up additional I am permissions
sound to the service accounts so now
what's left to do you're gonna come here
to create a VM instances right creating
disk images how do you make sure you
manage the access to those to secure
those resources and that's what the
section is the talk we're gonna be
talking about so let's have a quick
review of who a cache showed earlier
about our policy hierarchies I Google
all four four levels of hierarchies
organization folders projects and the
resources so any you can set up
permissions
policies on each of a level and any
level down below will automatically
inherit it so for example if I want to
give an architect the image user role
for all the team a so then I can go
ahead set a policy on the folder level
team a then this architect automatic
become the in the image user role for
all the project a you know project two
and Excel show any projects under the
under the folder this give you a lot of
flexibility to use but sometimes you may
want the opposite you actually want to
run into the situation you only want to
give access to particular resource
instead of you know grant at a higher
level so what would you do there you can
set a policies on to the individual
resource like VMs disks but probably
many people are familiar with compute
engine I am you may ask me I didn't know
that you were able to do so I thought
that the lowest level you can set a
policy with a projects level and you're
right until this week I actually very
excited to let you know that we are a
kind of support resource level I am in
beta very soon for you guys highly
anticipated feature seems like great and
that will allows you to do is exactly to
said I am policies on individual
resource like VMs disks this totally
enables a whole new set of use cases for
example a calming use cases with the
organization people often like to share
images with other developers or
different users yet with other resource
level I am they have the given image
user
for the whole project or above right but
sometimes we don't give them access to
all the image just the production unit
you measuring before I resource Allah I
am what you had to do was create a
separate project and only put the
particular image in that project so that
in the granted Policy Center the project
level that's a Baltimore and a lot of
management overhead right so with this
resource level I am you can simply just
granted the I am policy onto the
particular image in this example here I
want to grant the beta test group the
access to D particular beta image and
just by simple one line of code you can
achieve that now so here's a real world
example of sharing images as we were
talking about the scenario right so now
you can create one single image project
and putting your production image
together with our beta testing image in
the same project and only granted
developers access to the production
image so to make sure everyone is the
most supported a verified version and
giving the beta testers access to the
bay that has an image justice so now you
probably started thinking yeah I can set
I am policies on each Bay that has an
image to give the beta testers but yet
if I have many of the beta testing image
I have to set the policy on individual
image you know every time would that be
a little bit kind of a lot of work to do
right and we have thought about that for
you so if you want to have another way
to manage your resources access a scale
they'll be happy to find out another
beta feature that's coming soon to you
which is name prefix I am condition what
is allowing to do is exactly manage your
resources under the condition based on
name prefix so let's backtrack a little
bit to talk about what is conditional I
am first as I mentioned earlier I am is
allowing to define who can do what and
where resource is ray and now
conditional I am giving you additional
power which is adding a condition now to
the I am access so why wouldn't grant
access unless the condition is also met
in this name prefix condition we'll say
for example you can grant beta testers
the image user on a project but only if
the image the name is starting with beta
that way you can achieve what I just
mentioned by setting one policy the beta
tester groups will have all the access
to all the images starting with named
beta that's even included images yet we
can create as long as you created them
under the beta you know and ask or name
all the all your develop our beta
testers will have access to the image
another common use case customers asked
for to use that you can utilize this
name prefix condition is to build that
this is so-called a developer playground
many companies when they have a new
developer joining in they like to put
them all in the same project to test out
to build their prototypes because you
know creating each one an individual
project is a lot of overhead yet they
don't
each vari developer to accidentally
stamp up upon other people's resource so
having the setting up the name previous
condition to base on each to developers
email address South solves the situation
so that each developer host you only
have access to the resources starting
with their names and yet they can still
enjoy within the same project the
convenience and also the high profile
network performance more excitingly you
will find out condition I am not only
allowing to do name prefix basic
condition we have a two more type of
conditions with support which is access
level and the date/time condition access
level you to utilize the security
context seeing the George Kasia
mentioned earlier that we will look at
it the raw attributes comes in from the
request and then to decide even for
example the in sediments say can
manipulate instance right but you can
say any actions to manipulate the
instance for production project this
request needs to come coming from my
core network that way so even even the
in sediments sitting in their home
trying to do some work the request will
be rejected so giving you another layer
of security and protection daytime
condition just as the name suggests they
allow you to get a timer around your
condition so that you can say grant a
powerful access to your uncle you know
as our ease but only during their uncle
hours before this you had a to quench
access and the remove access manual
at the end of their uncle time but now
you can just simply set up a condition
time based condition and it can be
recurring as well so it can help you
manage that all right so we talked a lot
about I am conditional IMS resource I am
to help you better manage your resources
let's talk about another dimension and
go to how to manage the access for your
organization which is the famous
organizational policy organization
policies are meant to work together
serve a set of am policies but there's a
key difference which is Oracle policies
the enforcement will be there regardless
of I am access so for example if you
utilize the first example shows that no
external IP Oracle policy you can set
that on your project to folder or
organization level saying oh in my
organization for example I don't want
our VMs to be created with its own IP
then even the person supposed to have
the I am permission like a compute
admins wouldn't be able to do so so this
helps preventing a lot of human errors
against the organizational policy
enforced and whatever level you're
granted and similar as I in policy and
their level below automatically
inherited a compute engine will have a
bunch of very useful policies they can
read about like trust an image disables
your port access et cetera there are
particular to more organization policies
who will have to call out and we really
think you should know about them and
they will highly recommend you to enable
them the first ones domain restricted
organization sharing on a stream policy
what is allowing to restrict the
resources wouldn't be shared outside
their organization we have seen mistakes
done from before from a customer instead
for example their developer go home and
they're trying to do some work but
accidentally share that ISM image with
with their IP with their own gmail
account and there is information leaked
there with this organization policy you
can secure that resources wouldn't be
shared to anywhere else at your
organization the next one disabled
service account keys this is to speak is
back work as mentioned earlier we want
to have a Google we recommend you to use
Google manage that he instead of
user-generated
shows and if you enable this org policy
will prevent exactly user managed
generate the key so that you wouldn't
have a long leaving Keys that the
developers hold and then I suppose
additional risk for your organization to
our environment and we'll have a bunch
more organization policies you can
introduce for you yes you can read them
online probably better than what I can
say each about them but I think more
interesting it will be interesting find
out how is a real customer like two
Sigma's said happen utilize these ion
policies and/or policies build their
environment so we're happy we're
happening right Nick the head of cloud
security to sigma2 tell us about your
story Thank You Sofia if we're also very
excited about item conditions and
conditional rolls my name is Nick to
sigmah I'll talk a little bit about our
business to put the threat model into
context we're a technology driven
data-driven quantitative investment
manager really what that means is we use
computers to analyze a ton of data sets
and try to make market decisions based
of that we're obviously very worried
about external attackers though we have
a very small external profile so
although we're worried about volcano
fortresses we're also worried about our
internal users and that's not to say
that we don't trust our people there's
some extent to which we don't trust them
but we do trust them but if you follow
security and compromises you know that
sophisticated attackers or targeting
people with legitimate access to data
and we have some sort of friction
whereby we need our people to have
access to the data and the resources
they need in order to do their jobs but
then also mitigate the risk of mistakes
or intentional compromises so we want to
protect our IP and one of the big use
cases we have for computer engine is
really as an extension of our data
center we run a lot of trading
simulations or sort of model tests and
simulations that use tons of compute and
that's not exposed to the Internet at
all it's it's in a hybrid type
environment so you know things like what
Sofia mentioned is we don't want
external IPS in that environment even
though there's no internet
access mistakes can happen and we
believe very strongly in
defense-in-depth you don't want to be
one error or one failure of a control or
one compromise away from being on the
front page of the papers or in our case
potentially out of business so we apply
organization policies that are really
cheap and easy to implement control but
with really powerful implications like
no external IP is something else that's
really interesting to us is a really
useful feature is the ability to connect
to compute instance the serial console
if you have a network outage and
troubleshoot it our issue is that that
doesn't take into account any of our
firewall policies or network
configurations or we hate that and we
turn it off you can tackle this again
via I am but one of our use cases again
in enabling velocity for our teams is my
partner team that runs this environment
would really hate it if I didn't allow
them the ability to configure metadata
on VM instances where you can turn this
on or off like they need that for
bootstrapping so a safe compromise is to
use this organization policy to enforce
that control and then be able to be more
lenient on I am again we we really want
to be restrictive about what images we
use we have a lot of custom
configuration that goes into those so we
have as suggested in the best practices
we have a single project where our
trusted image is built and then we use
an old policy to configure our
environments then only images from that
environment can be booted up and used
the flip side of that is also obviously
really important like we to have a
developer sandbox like everybody else
and we don't want in that environment
that's wide open and connected to the
Internet our images that are baked with
our IP in some cases and in other cases
sensitive configuration details to be
used at all so we use another old policy
for that and finally I Sophia mentioned
domain restricted sharing really is a
no-brainer for us it's it's super easy
to implement and these things really
provide us a lot of access your again
other best practices this Israeli
defense in depth like we were live very
strongly on using custom maíam roles
only we tailor our roles based on the
least privilege and we use a whole host
of other services for our security
posture but these offerings and the ones
that have been discussed today are
really essential for us into
of enabling our business without adding
unnecessary friction either to our
security team or to our client teams so
with that I'll hand to Siri to wrap up
with the final section of how to secure
your environment Thank You Nick so hi
everyone my name is sorry I have another
product manager on the GCE team and
actually first of all I just want to say
thank you so much Nick
for talking with us today it's been an
absolute blast and a privilege to be
able to work with you guys to really
secure your incredibly valuable IP so
thank thank you again let's hear another
round for Nick to sigmah great so I'm
here to take us home and talk about the
final step here in our six steps best
practices and I'm here to talk to you
guys about platform transparency and
data integrity so you may be wondering
right what does that mean so to boil it
down here at Google cloud your trust is
our top priority right we understand
that many of you many of our customers
really rely on Google cloud to run their
businesses right and we know that
wouldn't be possible without having deep
trust and how we administer our platform
so the way to think about this is when
we talk about platform transparency here
what we really mean is what are the
tools and what is the information that
we're giving you guys as our customers
to really have faith and trust and to
really build that trust in how we're
administering our platform right and as
we'll see that takes a few different
forms the first thing I want to talk
about is how your data is encrypted
right and so before I go any further I
just want to say that at Google cloud
regardless of how you store your data
with us we are going to be encrypting
your data at rest
full-stop right and in the spirit of
transparency thank you cash in the
spirit of transparency you can go online
if you google for example a Google cloud
security white paper we explode we have
a lot of white papers and other
resources for y'all so that you can read
about our security best practices in
general how we do that encryption at
rest things like that so I would highly
encourage all of you if you're
interested to go take a look at that
following this presentation what I'm
talking about here is the options that
we give you all in GCE and Google
compute engine for how you actually do
how we actually do that encryption at
rest right and so here you see we have
three different options so I go left to
right and they kind of fall on the
spectrum of automation so how much
control we give versus how automated the
encryption actually is so we're start
with the one on the Left which is
encryption by default right so if you go
into Google cloud compute engine you
spin up a disk you spin up an image or a
snapshot and you just have all the
default parameters we will encrypt that
for you automatically at rest
no questions asked using our world class
encryption methodologies right so you'd
have to worry about it you just go ahead
and spin it up encrypt it at risk now we
know that some of you as our customers
you may be work in industries like
banking or financial services or
consulting where you're expected or
you're legally obligated to have some
more rigor or more control in how your
data is protected at rest right and so
as a result of that we give you some
more options here to give you more
control over how your in debt is
actually encrypted so I'll talk about
that middle one next this is a thing
that we call customer managed encryption
keys and so here what you do is right
you create a key in another GCP service
called cloud key management service so
you create that key and then when you
create a disk or an image or a snapshot
in GCE what we go ahead and do is we ask
you hey which one of these keys do you
want to use to actually protect this
content right and so here you're
deferring the creation and the storage
of the keys to GCP but you're still in
full control of the lifecycle of that
key you can revoke access you can
disable the key you can delete it etc
right and then finally on the very right
there we have another option called
customer supplied encryption keys and so
in this case what happens is we just ask
you for the key and Google Cloud is
actually deferring the creation and
storage of the key to you the customer
right so this gives you full control you
when you create the disk for example we
ask you for the key we obviously don't
store it but we use it to encrypt your
content and the next time that disk is
used say a VM startup we go ahead and
ask you for that key again right so this
is full control and this is really
popular again in some of those verticals
like banking ok
switching gears of machine just kidding
continuing on like most features in GCE
these controls are available to you in
the UI in the command line or in the API
so here I'm going to show you just for
simplicity sake what it looks like in
the UI with these three options look
like in the UI so here this is the VM
creation page this is when you create a
VM we asked you to create a boot disk of
course and you can actually select
either the automatic option on the far
left where no questions asked we just go
ahead and do it for you in the middle
you'll see the option to specify a key
in key management service so that
drop-down is a set of keys you have
there and then on the far right
that's the customer supplied option
where we ask you what the key is you
input it in that box and you go ahead so
the takeaway here really is that you
know however you want to manage how your
data is encrypted at risk we may say can
we make it really easy for you to get
started and to get going with that so
switching gears a little bit another
question that we get asked at Google
cloud a lot is well hey you guys aren't
ministering our data how much access do
you have to it right are you reading it
constantly so we know a lot of you may
have sensitive data in our cloud that
you trust us with we know many of you
may also have auditors who asked the
same question right as part of doing
their job and so here the first thing I
want to start with is at Google cloud
right we do not access your data for any
other reason other than to fulfill our
contractual obligations to you ok so
that means whenever there's a data
access event right whenever someone goes
to access your data it has to have a
very strong business justification and
it has to be in line with that
particular statement they're fulfilling
our contractual obligations to you you
can go online again you can Google
access transparency and you can find out
the well-defined set of sub reasons for
why we access your data and it turns out
by far the most common one I think over
ninety ninety-five percent of these
access events happen because our
customers you guys asked us to access
your data as part of say a support case
right but on top of that you don't have
to take our word for it right whenever
Google accesses your data will create an
audit log for you in near-real-time
right so that you can hold us
accountable
that statement there right so let's take
a quick look at one of those audit logs
looks like so this it's the fonts
probably a little small so I just walked
through this autolog for those of you
maybe in the back who can't see so the
first thing you'll see is this is just a
standard audit log but it's created when
an access event happens when a Google
access event happens and the first thing
you'll see highlighted in yellow there
is we gave you a reason why we access
your data it is allowing us to one of
the sub reasons for fulfilling our
contractual obligations to you and so
here you see this is actually a customer
initiated support request and we even
give you the case number so you can
follow up understand why exactly we're
accessing your data here likely it's
because you asked us to and then in
green you see we give you a lot of
information around what exactly did
Google do with your data once we during
this access event right so which method
did we call which resource did we call
it on how long did it take what project
did it happened in etc right and so this
is really aligning with our goal with
our principle of making it really
transparent and how we administer our
platform and giving you our customers
the tools to hold us accountable for
that okay so that brings us to the end
just to quickly summarize right we
talked through six steps for best
practices in compute engine I see a lot
of you are taking pictures I just want
to remind you all that this like all
talks at Google cloud next is going to
be posted to YouTube so you can go watch
that drill into one of the steps that
was particularly interesting to you et
cetera right and the final thing I want
to leave you all with is this right
Google cloud like the rest of Google we
take security and privacy incredibly
incredibly seriously right so we're
constantly improving and we're really
really receptive to feedback right so
please you know we've worked with two
sigma we want that to be the the rule
not the exception we're really open to
working with you all we want to make
sure that what we're doing aligns with
your needs and we want to make sure we
address any gaps right so leave us
feedback go to user voice go to the
developer console leave us feedback
about this or really any other features
it really does help influence our
backlog influence our decisions right so
with that thank you all very much I hope
you have a good rest of your time
here
[Music]